and today we have doctors Bryant Lin and
Oliver Alami with us Bryant Lin is a
primary care physician educator and
researcher the Cornerstone of Dr Lynn's
work is keeping medicine focused on
humans patients providers families and
trainees and not lost in technology and
algorithms his research and educational
interests span one developing and
testing novel medical Technologies two
improving the health of Asian
populations with precision and
population health
and three increasing expression and
interconnections in the Health Community
with the humanities and arts Dr Lin
serves as Stan at Stanford as clinical
faculty in primary care and population
Health in the Department of Medicine
where he has invented and researched new
medical Technologies addressing unmet
human-centered needs and started the
consultative medicine clinic evaluating
patients with medical Mysteries
Dr Alami is a clinical professor of
vascular and endovascular surgery at
Stanford University and the Palo Alto VA
and serves as the Director of Stanford's
biodesign for digital health he is the
course director for biodesign for
digital health building for digital
health and co-founder of the open source
project Cardinal kit developed to
support sensor-based mobile research
projects his primary research focuses on
clinically validating the sensors and
smartphones and smart watches in
patients with cardiovascular disease and
translation of digital Health Solutions
Dr Lynn and Dr Alami thank you for being
with us and I will hand the controls
over to you for your presentation
thank you very much uh Jacqueline uh
it's great to be here welcome everyone
we have quite a few slides to go through
so I'm just going to run through here
are disclosures so our learning
objectives today to understand a
framework to evaluate new technologies
articulate value propositions the
limitations of digital health and also
appreciate the economic impacts of these
new techno Technologies I'm going to
just start from the very top and talk
about kind of why now why is it an
interesting time
and we're basically on an unsustainable
uh trajectory currently with regards to
costs of Health Care
um the U.S spends about 17 of its GDP on
health care and this continues to go up
about three to five percent a year and
you layer on top of that despite this
crazy spend that our outcomes aren't
that great uh compared to other nations
that spend a fraction of what we spend
at on top of that that we have a silver
tsunami or an aging Society
and then you add on top of that that we
just aren't producing enough clinicians
or providers to help
um address or meet the needs of all
these people that will have chronic
conditions
so any is the government realizes this
and for that reason any new innovation
that comes out that you know that will
be supported needs to meet the triple
aim or quadruple aim it really needs to
have
better outcomes than what currently
exists at a lower cost and to be
scalable and this just happens to be the
sweet spot for digital Health which we
believe or we Define as the convergence
of data connectivity and compute power
to increase access and provide
personalized Health Care to improve
outcomes at a lower cost and this is
just a high level framework you know it
all starts with the patient and the data
generated around that patient whether
it's through mobile app an in-person
visit in a clinic devices wearable
sensors that data data is then analyzed
in a way and insights are gathered from
that from that data which then feeds
back to the whole system
and
Healthcare is very very very complicated
it's very different than the Consumer
world when you think about innovating in
this space you have all these
stakeholders to think about uh whether
it's the insurance companies the
government
um
CMS what's unique about digital Health
when we do our needs finding for example
around this space when you think in the
through the scope of digital Health you
have to include the patient at home as
another stakeholder and that's what
makes this field so exciting and there
are certain enabling changes around data
Regulatory and reimbursement as well as
covet most recently that have really
pushed things afford and I'm just going
to touch at a very high level on what
these have been it all started
in 2009 with a high-tech act the U.S
government again was very aware of this
unsustainable trajectory and we all have
heard of the adage that if you can't
measure it you can't improve it
and um
so it was very clear that a lot we had a
lot of paper charts we didn't have
digital charts and the US government had
a very hard time even knowing like where
where is the spend what are the outcomes
like in these various settings it was
hard to measure so there was this huge
incentive to digitize the electronic
health record and there's various
meaningful use stages where it was kind
of a carrot and stick model where they
were providing funds to Hospitals and
Clinics to implement electronic health
records however they had to meet certain
criteria and it started with just basic
implementation electronic order entry
drug drug interactions for Meaningful
use stage one and then it went to
uh five percent uh patients need to be
able to view download and transmit data
which ended up just becoming the patient
portal for Meaningful use stage two and
these are just small segments of of
these requirements but what you're
seeing here is are the the government
kind of mandates which pushed not only
the digitization but also now bringing
the patient into the the picture and and
realizing that
um they needed to make sure that this
benefited and that the patient had the
ability to view this data it was kind of
the sap Oracle moment you know that way
back in
um 2009 when you know this really
happened in the 1970s and all in the
other Industries and by 2016 about 96 of
the U.S Healthcare System had certified
electronic health records however
there's still the government still
realized that even though the data was
digitized it was living siled in these
these various institutions or Health
Systems
and so the next evolution of meaningful
use had to be around not only
allowing patients to view their data
through a portal but how can we get the
data to flow outside of the electronic
health records so they said that the
data needed to be available or
accessible electronically via an API and
at that point they hadn't quite
specified which API but that was the
beginning of the hs7 fire standard
being implemented slowly and coming on
onto the Horizon and we'll talk about
that more in March of 2020 the 21st
century cures act final rule was passed
and this is a huge rule
um
and this can is also it has an
information blocking component as well
uh which is really important uh and it
and it mandated as this fire the fire
standard based API to be the API so now
Define the business rules of how data
needs to be exchangeable and how the
data should flow and then on top of that
they uh they also man mandate that all
elements eventually need to be exposed
via an API or electronically and
interestingly this just this just um
because of Coba things were delayed
quite a bit in terms of men when it was
mandated but on October 6th of last
month
or October 6 which is last month of this
year is when this finally came into
um you know came into law and it's it's
not being enforced quite yet it's not
clear how it's being enforced you can
imagine there's a lot of pushback but uh
this is very much uh a reason why the
data is now available and being
um and being made available if we talk
about reimbursement there have been also
a lot of changes
um which make
or try to create an ecosystem right for
digital Health most of the US is still
fee for service based meaning that you
get incentivized for heads and beds
doing procedures keeping the care within
the four walls of the hospital and again
the government realized that this is not
really in line with long-term with
lowering costs and preventive health and
and their the government's one of the
biggest uh Spenders you know they they
pay over approximately 50 percent of all
the health care bills in the United
States and because of this they've
implemented a lot of quality uh payment
programs and metrics there have been
various various iterations whether it's
through an ACO more recently what's
gained a lot of um
traction and growth is the Medicare
Advantage program which is basically
Medicare managed by
Insurance other outside insurance
companies such as Optum chenmed Oak
Street Health Humana
Kaiser at another they all participate
in Medicare Advantage plans and what's
unique about this is that these
insurance companies or Healthcare
delivery organizations actually going at
risk for these patients meaning they get
a bucket of money at the end of the at
the beginning of the year and all right
are then challenged to take care of
these patients
um and they're very incentivized to
reach out to patients Implement all the
digital Health tools they can for
preventative measures telemedicine
whatever it may be
so some example some other examples of
where digital Health has grown or
integrated delivery networks such as
Kaiser
Ochsner health system is another nice
integrated delivery Network system in
the in the south in New Orleans and I
believe personally that they're one of
the most Advanced Health Care Systems
with a really Advanced Digital Health
offering currently they have
antihypertension programs CHF Management
Programs diabetes management pregnancy
programs they have something called an O
Bar which is kind of like a Genius Bar
where
um I'll walk you through a patient's
story for example if I was diagnosed
with hypertension in Epic they'd put in
the order for me to become to join this
program I would walk out of the clinic
to one of these o bars pick up a
subsidized blood pressure cuff they
would connect it with my phone right
there at the at the O Bar and then I
would get text messages telling me to
check my blood pressure several times a
week that would go to Epic and a
pharmacist would then review the meds
and based on a protocol would send text
messages back to tell me to either go up
or down on my blood pressure medication
and they have solid data on this showing
that they can get much better tighter
blood pressure control in a much shorter
time so it's a great success story of
how digital health and the right setting
with the right incentives can really
benefit patients
self-insured employer employers are also
very very interested in digital health
programs at Starbucks for example pays
more for health insurance for their
employees than they do for coffee beans
to roast other coffee so they also have
the freedom to implement any sort of
programs to better manage and uh
chronic conditions and or any condition
really that their members have and turns
out musculoskeletal conditions such as
lower back pain joint pain is a huge is
a huge spend for all these organizations
and they've for example implemented
hinge Health which is a remote physical
therapy
program to help again navigate patients
away from surgery and more towards
Physical Therapy which is shown to be as
effective if not better or more
effective and then I wanted to touch on
the regulatory as well FDA has been very
forward thinking
in terms of
addressing all the AI software or other
software and will it be regulated will
it not be regulated they've put out
quite a few
guidelines that are available online
they also have a website the the digital
Health Center of Excellence website
which you can go to there's a link
posted here and they're actually very
good at responding to questions so if
you have any question about whether your
solution is going to be regulated or not
regulated you can go ahead and send them
an email it takes them a while to
respond but they provide a very
comprehensive response and I highly
recommend folks to do that if they have
any questions they also made it very
clear that we you know they will not
generally regulate wellness products and
I'll go into an example of that and the
future such as omada omada health is
basically took a program that was
delivered in the YMCA in person which
was a diabetes prevention program
digitized it uh added you know connected
scale coaching group sessions that are
remote as well as health education and
their program is uh not currently being
regulated by the FDA so it's considered
a general wellness program as an example
and then you have other kind of software
you know the Apple watch itself isn't
isn't a regulated device however the
software The Irregular Rhythm
notification for afib is while other
metrics that have come out such as the
passive
walking speed passive six minute walk
test VO2 max or temperature gauge
they've chosen not to go through FDA
clearance so just to give you a high
level
view of the complexity of this and and
really in some I would say for this
first section that
you know what has what is really a I
think a huge Insight is that there's
been a lot of clarity from HHS the
Department of Health and Human Services
onc the office of the national
coordinator that really they want the
patient in their View
um they want to drive things towards a
consumer or patient authorized data
exchange so give the patient the key to
unlock Health Data and if you are an
innovator in this Healthcare space and
you you would like
you know to have access to your uh
someone you're trying to serve or help
with your product that they the patient
or your customer has the right to to ask
for that data and now we have a defined
way to get that data through the fire
apis and so on at least that's the
vision
um so I can I wanted to just plug
Cardinal kit but we can get into that a
little later and I'm going to hand it
over to my partner in crime
Dr Landry great thanks so much Dr Alami
uh for a fantastic uh Whirlwind uh
overview of uh the structural changes uh
that have been happening that have
encouraged and some could argue
discouraged digital health I just wanted
to zoom out a little bit it's hard to
have a discussion about the future
excuse me of digital Health without
talking about technology and Medicine
generally you know sometimes as
technologists we always view technology
is always a good thing and in medicine
it's a complicated question because uh
you know we have a principle among
Physicians that are Hippocratic Oath of
Do no harm
and it's not always clear that
technology is beneficial you can see a
company like intuitive surgical a
well-known company this is from a an
article an editorial in nature one of
the nature magazines uh and just a quote
talks about how intuitive is loved by
surgeons and patients alike for its ease
of use and faster recovery times
it's less invasively conventional
procedures but the robot's two million
dollar price tag and negligible effect
on cancer comes is sparking concern that
it's crowding out more affordable
treatment so you know not clearly uh Do
no harm and maybe there's some benefits
but they're also some concerns as well
about cost and potentially potentially
preventing other Innovation from
occurring
and then you know as a doctor it's hard
not to talk about epic uh Dr Alami
talked about emrs a few minutes ago uh
and uh you know there's a lot of
resistance to adopting emrs initially
and epic of course is the the biggest
most influential uh EMR out there but
you can see you know sometimes there are
benefits even though it was painful can
be painful to implement this was a study
looking at the implementation of an EHR
in the critical care setting and it
didn't affect length of stay but did
decrease the risk of mortality decreased
mortality rates in the ICU and that was
thought to be due to potentially
medication error decreases as well so
not always good not always bad we need
to have a framework to evaluate
technology and Medicine in particular
digital health
there are lots of perspectives in our
digital Health course Dr Alami and I
really look at a product development
perspective and that's the entrepreneur
corporate perspective but there are a
lot of different perspectives out here
just like you know if you ever visit the
Leaning Tower of Pisa where are you in
this big crowd can give you a really
different view of what the Leaning of
Tower Pisa is and what it looks like and
how it impacts you and there's so many
stakeholders in this environment Dr Lami
talked about the seven-headed monster
eight-headed monster and lots of
different goals you know around
improving Health but money saving money
making money curing disease preventing
disease many many goals around Health in
general and digital Health in particular
for example in entrepreneur can use this
framework you know what do I worked on
do I look at a large automatic clinical
need do I look at something that's
scalable has a pathway has a regulatory
pathway a business model easy way to
distribute and sell the product uh do
you have any competitive Advantage you
know are there other uh things you need
to prove that it works like clinical
trials how to use analytics to show that
your your solution is something that
helps outcomes or helps some sort of
goal that you're going after such as
saving money or making money
now of course there's a broad societal
framework looking at population Health
can we you know from the government and
um from societal point of view we want
to improve the health of populations
where you know we'd love to of course
improve the health of individuals but
looking at it apart from a population
Health that can help you Marshal
resources you know how do you put your
money behind certain Solutions uh so
they can help the largest number of
people looking at prevention and
management of disease value-based care
this is where the dollars come into
place and then this this is this new
part uh which really digital Health
enables how do you analyze this how do
you use traditional research but also
new methods of analysis to show that
new Solutions are actually doing what
they intend to do and not causing any
harm again
um so I wanted to also just briefly
touch on what population health is
um so the CDC defines population health
is uh bringing significant health
concerns into focus and addressing how
those resources can be allocated to
overcome the problems that drive poor
health conditions in the population so
that's again one perspective from the
CDC so you can see how depending on your
perspective you may use a different
framework to evaluate technology
so today I'd like to go back to as Dr
Alami talked about the triple aim uh
from the ihi and the triple aim again
just to remind you is focus around
improving patient care the patient
experience of care which is around both
quality and satisfaction improving the
health of populations and reducing the
per capita cost of Health Care so today
we'll provide a few cases and talk about
how we use that framework to evaluate
new technologies new digital
Technologies
so we're going to talk about mental
health oncology
a couple of cases on collagen as well as
I didn't include here a wearables Dr
Alami will talk about case studies and
wearables as well
so digital mental health is really an
incredibly exciting area lots of
unicorns billion dollar startups in this
area uh focused mainly around virtual
care connecting people to Providers and
tools not quite sure if they improve
outcomes it's not clear
here are some potential benefits
um you know this is from a practical
prospective a functional perspective
notifications you can monitor perhaps
track your own mental health you can
share what's going on connecting to a
professional being part of community and
then having a dashboard just have a
really big overview either from the
provider clinician side or even from the
patient side about how your care is
going
you can see here they're just focusing
in the therapy aspect of mental health
you know traditional approaches uh are
in a uh looking at uh acceptance and
commitment therapy act CBT PDT cvt's
cognitive behavioral therapy and PDT
psychodynamic therapy and then of course
in B there's traditional treatment
traditional face-to-face treatment and
digital Health which sort of the
digitization of uh A and B as well so
kind of how do you convert these
approaches uh and enable them digitally
so just our case today we'll talk about
cerebral so the cerebral's been in the
news
um you can see from their website it's
just a screen capture from their website
their tagline is expert help for your
emotional health
connecting you with professionals
basically at a subscription fee
um this is again from their website
talking about what their results are
what their outcomes are eighty percent
of members have a niche visit so great
Improvement in Access and it makes sense
uh decrease in depression symptoms they
don't really talk about how they track
this or what the metric is and then uh
you know significant impact a large
number of people saying their anxiety is
better so great these are you know
sounds like all great things
so what's their business model well it's
um you know really a monthly
subscription fee you may be able to get
insurance to pay for part of this uh but
there's a 30 monthly access fee that is
not covered by insurance and then you
may be able to get insurance to cover
for extra things as well as medication
but there's a problem with this model
you know incentives are misaligned Wall
Street Journal had a series of articles
about how uh they really had a great
increase in number of patients that
they're managing but it seemed like a
significant percentage of these were
coming to cerebral for access to ADHD
medications uh and there were problems
with how cerebral evaluated these
patients and their misincensives
disincentives well misaligned incentives
uh for people for their providers to
actually provide easy access because
they don't want to lose customers
um if they are deemed not to be needing
these types of medications which are
controlled medications
and uh you know resulted in more bad
news you can see that they cut out
recently Wall Street Journal reported
they cut 20 of their staff
um due to this bad publicity so you know
these are challenging right this this is
a company that did improve access
seemingly improved symptoms uh but there
was a negative side due to uh the
incentives and conflicts of interest
inherent in the way the company was
structured
so again let's go back to our framework
uh improving the patient experience of
care well one could argue that the
satisfaction was improved right so some
people did benefit you could argue about
quality Wall Street Journal focused on
the case study where there was one
person under treatment who had a very
bad outcome so this is unclear this
first bullet on our framework uh did it
improve the health of populations main
maybe again depends on the net net
benefit we don't know we don't really
have enough data this is all secret to
us right at least we only know what
they've reported I don't know if that
many uh peer-reported peer-reviewed
reports from cerebral and then reducing
costs again unclear whether they really
reduce costs there's this additional
monthly fee that's required so from a
Health Equity standpoint it's not really
improving access unless you're able to
pay for it
let's move on to oncology seven more
Adventures a well-known Venture from in
the area of digital Health has a great
and I encourage you to take a look at
their website a great kind of overview
of how digital health is involved in
oncology and this is a quite a broader
review and you can see it's there are
many areas touched including care
navigation put around clinical trials
detection and diagnosis we research and
data management and clinical decision
support so really a lot of companies in
the space very popular area
you can see how different Technologies
and again the goal today is not really
to delve into these details but you can
see how different Technologies can
really impact potentially possibly many
stakeholders and benefit oncology care
let's focus on this case here so this is
I think the simplest case of where
clearly digital Health impacted
um the health of patients undergoing
oncology care something called patient
reported or e-patient report electronic
patient reported outcomes systems so
there are many objectives for these
systems but we're really going to look
at
you know how this affected uh patients
care and as part of a clinical trial but
improve the outcomes for patients who
basically self-reported their symptoms
through electronic digital means
so this is a system developed out of
Memorial slim Kettering uh and you can
see again the details aren't that
important but patients were able to
report their symptoms that they're uh
having as they underwent treatment for
uh cancer and uh they of course would
they're someone who was looking at this
information uh the clinical team and was
able to potentially the ideas they were
able to intervene early uh and so uh
improved treatment and accessibility for
the patients
and this is looking at Survivor survival
so we always think about oncology in
terms of you know months of survival
for drugs and treatments uh you know
really advanced technology and this is
really uh kind of a workflow
intervention right you're enabling
patients to report their symptoms to
their care team you can see it here it's
really amazing uh you can see the dark
line as these are survival curves uh so
usual correct care there was a higher
mortality with usual care than in the
patient report symptom monitoring group
uh by
uh and the difference was quite Stark so
this was a seminal article in the space
and led to the American Society of
clinical oncologists to put this in
their guidance documents that this is
recommended for anyone receiving
clinical Cancer Care
uh so let's go back to our framework
talk about improving patient experience
and Care clearly you know patients are
able to talk about their symptoms their
their undergoing uh seem to improve
quality mortality improve the health of
populations decrease mortality and we
don't know about the costs yet so that's
something interesting but these
Frameworks are fairly low cost didn't
seem to require additional clinical
Staffing
um so it seems like it checks all the
boxes for us
let's talk about another case in
oncology this is Grail Gallery
um so this is what's called a
multi-cancer early detection test so
it's basically they're looking for tumor
DNA and you basically pay it's a blood
test it's around a thousand dollars or
so uh and they will do tests looking for
the presence or absence of tumor DNA in
your blood
and uh you know you can see here again
this is from their website around 70 of
deaths are caused by cancers that aren't
screened for so this is part of the push
for how do we screen for more cancers we
have very few cancers such as colon
cancer breast cancer uh cervical cancer
uh and um some could argue prostate
cancer that we actually can screen for
uh but most of cancers we can't screen
for
so this is how they look they look at
sulfur DNA from cancer cells you know
different than normal cells this is what
they're detecting
um this is a performance from their
large study which was published High
specificity so 99 1.1 specificity uh but
really not great positive predictive
value so 38 so if you have a positive
test what's the likelihood that you do
have cancer so less than 50 percent
um and then the negative predictive
value is very good but you know of
course most people are not going to have
cancer and you need to screen 189 people
in order to detect one cancer
and this is from a different study kind
of a value-based study you looked at and
you can see that the mced plus usual
care so Gallery plus usual care pushed
diagnosis to earlier stages which
presumably will enable uh better
treatment and lower mortality we don't
know that yet
and you can look here the costs of
course it did increase costs uh
increased costs of screening
um and you can see at every level uh did
increase costs across almost across the
board except for stage three and stage
four because they're pushing more people
into early stage detection
and you can see here this is this is
again I won't go into the weeds with the
quality of quality adjusted life years
uh but uh setting the price around a
hundred thousand dollars uh per quality
adjusted life years something a lot of
these studies do and you can see there's
a tremendous variability so we don't
really honestly have the data to assess
this yet
so because of that
um you know it's interesting because
it's a it's not reimbursed by Insurance
there's a lot of false positive risk
um you know if you offer this to every
Medicare beneficiary you know according
to Dr Welch you could bankrupt Medicare
so this is of concern so we really need
to study these Technologies uh quite
well before they're approved by
insurance
um of course because of this we don't
know on a randomized basis uh so the
National Health Service in UK is
studying whether randomizing people to
um Gallery testing versus usual care you
know what the outcomes are in the long
run and then of course they'll track
costs as well so that'll be very
interesting this randomized controlled
study
so looking at the framework for gallery
you know it's possibly we're increasing
quality and satisfaction hard to say you
know false positive risks of course are
not something we want as patients or
providers uh potentially improving the
health of populations again what's the
Cascade of false pause of the diagnosis
hard to quantify and the costs may
increase uh overall so unclear on this
framework whether this type of test is
something that as a society and
fulfilling the triple aim something we
should support so stay tuned
um going to hand it back to uh Dr Alami
to talk about the next guest
perfect thank you so I was gonna get
into a little bit about wearables now
Rune Labs is a really fascinating
company their Precision neurology
company and they basically not only
ingest data from Imaging but what's
unique about this FDA 510 kfda clearance
that they got received recently this
year
their strive PD software or ecosystem
you know leverages the Apple watch in
order to kind of track symptoms so
something that's really hard
for neurologists is to get that feedback
from patients you know did the
medication adjustment improve your
symptoms or worsen your symptoms and
through this kind of strive PD ecosystem
you they can more objectively track how
the medication is affecting the patient
system so here's an example where a
wearable a consumer wearable really
um
combined with some other components and
clinical factors was wrapped into this
FDA approved product by a roon lab so
that's a really interesting
case study the neurology space this is
more forward looking but I thought it
was pretty fascinating again a consumer
device so it's a a watch that can detect
atrial fibrillation there's a big study
that was just awarded a massive Grant
it's going to be multi-institutional
study led by Northwestern in Chicago
where for patients with atrial
fibrillation who would normally stay on
a blood thinner and anticoagulant to
help prevent strokes and so on
they actually would monitor the atrial
fibrillation uh because there is a
subset of these patients that go in and
out of atrial fibrillation so while
they're when they have afib the uh study
would then the study app would tell them
to take their pill uh their blood
thinner and if they don't have afib
um they wouldn't so here's another just
interesting
kind of forward-looking
um
study to see how wearables could be used
and mixed into the clinical practice or
or just care and again remember digital
health is you know care outside the four
walls of the hospital where most most
people live most of their time they
don't we don't spend much time in the
clinics or the hospital so that's what
makes this really exciting
and then this is a really I'm surprised
alio doesn't get more attention so this
is a another wearable it's a patch with
sensors multiple sensors that you put
over
um what's called an arterial venous
fistula and EB fistula or AV graft and
this is something that dialysis patients
have and need for long-term dialysis
access and what's really challenging
with dialysis patients is that they're
fluid
and electrolyte shifts are quite
dramatic and
they actually have to report when they
go to their dialysis centers they need
to report you know what were their
potassium levels what it was their
hemoglobin hematocrit and this patch
through artificial intelligence and all
the sensors is able to provide and they
received FDA approval for this is able
to provide a potassium prediction
hemoglobin hematocrit prediction you
know blood count predictions can monitor
all the vital signs oxygen saturation
and what's another really interesting
thing about alio is that they not only
provide the patch but they've spent a
lot of time thinking about the clinician
portal how is how are we going to
deliver this information number number
one and number two on the patient's side
it's really Plug and Play so the patient
gets this Hub that you see here on the
on the screen right
and that plug that Hub just
automatically automatically syncs with
the device when they're home or close to
the hub so there's very little
um you know work or or it's very passive
it doesn't require much uh on the
patient side which is huge because uh
you know we can all dream up these great
ideas for monitoring but if it involves
a lot of work from the on the patient
side it's actually
um it you it's really hard to get
significant engagement so the more
passive something can be the
um more likely you are to be getting
quality data not to have what we call
missing data
so that is
um kind of the summary there I'm going
to give it back to Dr Lynn to close it
out here great thanks Dr Alami so yeah
just to sum it up it's already here
we're already in the digital future
we'll continue to evolve evolve evolve
we really need to watch out for
misaligned incentives so uh the reason
why there's so much attention in this
space is because there's thought to be a
lot of money at stake lots of you know
very valuable companies uh so from a
healthcare perspective we need to watch
for that and make sure that and that
benefit is there uh looking at the
benefits versus the risks so there's
some unexpected risks unpredicted risks
uh but there may be some unexpected
benefits like you know I would not have
expected epic to change mortality uh
among ICU patients uh and then lastly we
need to study these digital Health tools
interventions
um with traditional Technologies
traditional methods clinical trials but
also we need to constantly constantly
have feedback constantly have analytics
to show that really we are not causing
harm uh and showing that hey how can we
do better the beauty of digital care is
that there are a lot of incremental
things we can change it's not like a
surgical device where
um you know the days are gone where you
can tweak a surgical device and you know
immediately have that out in the market
there's a lot of things that you need to
do from a regulatory standpoint digital
health is not the case there are a lot
of things you can do and change about
digital Tools digital applications
digital interventions for health that
don't require regulatory change they can
be adjusted on the fly in conjunction
with workflow issues thank you for your
attention today and I hope you will also
check out our class and I think Jackie
will talk about that as well
okay let me begin with the first
question here
um could you elaborate on why the
government through HIPAA is holding on
to EDI standard to transmit patients
claim data to Clearinghouse
organizations instead of payer receiving
claims data directly via much better
insecure encrypted systems
what was that Sarah could you repeat the
question which standard the ADI uh can
you repeat about holding on to EDI
standard
so I you know I I'll be frank you know
I'm not
you know I don't know too much about
that in particular because it has to do
with the payers and I'm assuming we're
talking about claims data going from
um the hospital to the payers so I I
don't know much about that but I I do
know that they are trying to move
everything to more like fire-based
um protocols and standards that's that
that's something I do know uh
that's I don't know if you know much
more about that Brian
I don't know if it's the government
really holding on to it there I mean
there are definitely standards that are
mandated
um but like anything there's a lot of
slowness and you know how do you enforce
these things so I think it's sort of
there you've got to have a stick right
you have standards but you also anytime
you have standards you need to some sort
of have some sort of incentive how do
you make sure that everybody is kind of
uh following the mandates and the rules
that are set up
um so yeah my perspective is just that's
not necessarily built in there really
yet
um you know just sort of like uh you
know
um you know how when bmrs came out right
uh you know when when you're talking
about you know are you actually using
emrs the way it's supposed to be used so
you know they had incentives and and and
carrots and sticks there as well so yeah
but definitely not not an expert in that
area yeah
okay thank you and the next question is
how are the advances in Sharing Medical
Data impacted by HIPAA it seems like
there are many areas where data sharing
may cross over the line that HIPAA seeks
to protect yeah so I I love this I love
to I'm sorry Brian I'm going to jump in
here just because I'm really bullish
about this I I think HIPAA is there to
protect us you know hip is not a bad
thing it's a it's actually a good thing
and
I'm truly believe it's there to to help
us and again the government is really
pushing back against hospitals that's
that you know is trying to hold on that
are trying to hold on to their data and
not share their data again it goes back
to that one slide I gave or I showed
where I talked about the consumer driven
data exchange so it's really the patient
has the power and the government's made
it very very clear that you as a patient
if you want to get your data and now you
can get it electronically or at least
you're supposed to be able to Via the
fire API and this is really an important
detail because if you're an innovator in
the space and you want
to pull data from you know from one of
your users
um EHR you you now have the business
rules to be able to do that so you have
in theory you should be able to design
something and with your users permission
you should be able to or they should be
able to pull the data on your behalf and
I mean to help them ultimately
I hope that answers your question
I don't know Brian if you have anything
to add
I totally agree I think if it's there to
protect patients and yes there is
bureaucracy like in anything when you
have regulations but you know they're
surmountable for the entrepreneur and
for people working in this space it's a
lot about familiarity and remember HIPAA
is not it's it's a comedy this is where
it's challenging right it's a
combination of you have to have
processes in place and certain software
standards so that's what part of what
makes it complex uh but I agree with you
uh Oliver it's it's you know I think
patients are in control I was talking
with a company called Crescendo Health
where they're trying to enable this uh
where people have control and then if
they want to provide their data for
research or whatever they can do it so
we're making inroads it's it's a slow
process
yeah I'll also just say that for HIPAA
it's very much a shared responsibility
meaning like if I'm a startup and I'm
you know and I want to make sure I'm
HIPAA compliant it's a shared
responsibility meaning I as Brian Brian
said I have to have certain processes
and procedures in place
in terms of you know making sure that
everyone is trained on how to handle the
data
um we need to make sure that we have a
role well-defined roles in access
controls to the data you need to make
sure to have a business associates
agreement in place with all your
contract you know server
providers and database providers so it's
it's a kind of a shared responsibility
between you and your partners
um you can't just buy it necessarily
so it's it's a complex it's not as
complex as it seems I mean I'll I'll
just put it that way it's just more of a
process and procedure
um
thing so all right
there was a question about
um
as far as sharing data from the patient
isn't there a risk of patients
misreporting their condition or their
information
yeah Brian I don't I mean I can start
there again yeah
go ahead I think yeah okay yeah I know
100 I think
I'll give you a great example
the Apple watch irregular Rhythm
notification
100 it never calls an afib or an
irregular Rhythm from just one one
Rhythm detection it needs to read I
believe it's I don't I may misspeak here
but it's at least five separate readings
five separate consecutive readings that
need to be consistent before the
confidence you know their confidence
goes up to make a call like that this
isn't a regular rhythm because you're
right in the real world when you're
talking when you have sensors you're
going to have artifact you know did you
bang your arm against something or are
you walking are you jumping so these
these are real that's a really good
question
um from a sensor standpoint now whether
a patient puts in the right data or not
uh you know that I agree that's
something that um you almost have to
have like a double triple
check you have to ask a question maybe
in three different ways to make sure
that the answer is very consistent I
don't know Brian if you have anything
else
yeah I think oh sorry
I think um yeah it's it's I mean it's
constant about race this is kind of even
separate from digital Health right we
patients can tell us whatever and and I
think we're as Physicians are trained to
really well we're supposed to get an
appropriate history and physical and
really assess the real life part of
that's assessing the reliability of
course the default is to trust what the
patient's doing
um you know we're there for the patient
you can't always be in a situation where
you're not trusting uh what the
patient's telling you uh but you know
you want to verify especially if it's
something you're going to hinge your
opinion on but we do that even for other
things like pathology right if somebody
comes in with a cancer uh we at Stanford
have asked them to bring their get their
slides and their pathology slides and
our Pathologists will then look at them
just to confirm the diagnosis so you
know there are certain crucial times
where that data and verify today is
important sometimes it's not so I I
think it's an issue but I don't think
it's a
issue Central to digital Health it's
it's an issue just generally with
information flow and health
can you speak
to access to these products or tools
more Equitable but the design of them as
well
so localization multilingual
I'll make a comment I think we would do
a terrible job I'm the director of the
center for Asian health research and
education just from the language access
point I think it's horrible you know
when we when we have epic my health
right I have you know we kind of buy
this big
compendium of pre-canned
instructions for patients and I've had
many patients tell me oh this looks like
it was just translated directly it
doesn't it's really lost a lot of this
it's almost like they just took their
English version and Google translated it
and then just using my health right it's
it's in English right and then you know
changing the language and then there's
of course digital health literacy uh so
I think we're doing a terrible job I I'm
not aware of I don't know Oliver if you
are if there's any good
system level efforts I think there's a
smaller level and they're very much like
Stanford we're trying to do better I
just had a meeting with our
um health patient experience people at
the hospital trying to improve this for
non-english speakers uh so to me it
seems to be really done at the lower
level the hospital and the clinic level
I I don't know of any broader efforts to
do this at least at the government level
I don't know Oliver have you heard of it
well I know
I know
um
I know it's definitely in the in the
radar or uh is because it is becoming
more and more part of the requirements
for uh certain grants I know the state
of California for example the California
Department of Aging just put out a huge
RFP for
um just training home care workers and
part of it was
it was very clear they uh it needed to
be accessible
um or accessibility was a big uh factor
and that that speaks to the digital
divide as well as literacy
um
and so on so I I think you know we're
not great because
you see the most implementation the
greatest implementation is typically
uh for those that can pay and that's the
top of the wealth pyramid and so it's
not necessarily Fair because the bottom
of the wealth pyramid is often you know
is often overlooked but I'll be honest
in the last there's been a huge push
around uh you know just innovating for
the bottom uh of that wealth pyramid to
make sure that more people can benefit
uh from you know from all these
Innovations but nothing
um
I just I want to just say that at least
we're talking about it at least we're
um we're you know thinking about it and
they're definitely I mean it's very
clear there's a digital divide there's a
literacy divide that we need to address
to make things more equitable
I mean I'll give another quick I mean
this is kind of tangentially directed I
mean the CMS just last week expanded the
um
kind of the
um the rule to for example we know that
the postpartum
uh African-American women have a much
higher mortality rate than let's say
white counterparts and it turned out
when they did the research that a lot of
this mortality postpartum came after 60
days and currently the federal federally
mandated Medicaid coverage is only up to
60 days and they've because of this uh
finding they expand they extended the
federally mandated coverage
for Medicaid for women up to a year and
40 of births in the U.S are are under
Medicaid and most often those 40 percent
or many of those women would lose their
insurance after 60 days before this rule
so there are you know there are efforts
uh to provide continual support
um you know when you're thinking or
looking through the equity lens
thank you um
questions too
with regard to kind of data privacy
um let me put one here
um
and also access so actually first
question
um can you discuss the about future
directions between uh interoperability
between data from these Home Health
devices and integrating these this data
with existing EMR systems
that's a tough one I mean I know I
believe this is the case still I mean we
have some very very we have few examples
where we can actually write into the EHR
but
um
we don't have I don't think we have a
great system
you know to take that data and to put it
together intelligently
um
currently
um for patients instead of in places
such as Ochsner what they have done is
they basically create
reports because it's a lot of time you
can imagine the time series data for
example a watch or activity or something
it's a lot of data and so they try to
condense that data into reports that
then you can click into from the EHR
through a a hyperlink
so that's what I've seen and these are
through these dashboards and I know we
even at Stanford they do they do that
quite a bit for certain projects
um but that's it's not
definitely not a norm for these data
streams to be integrated with the EHR I
would say it's an exception but it can't
be done and that's what fire is trying
to imp is to enable
yeah I agree with uh Dr alamio oh we
just make a comment that in the cases
where they are enabled like you know I'm
a primary care doctor I get and I cover
my colleagues and some colleagues are
great about getting patients you know
their devices connected and we get these
reports and there you have these huge
time time series data but the vast
majority of people send nothing
so it's amazing you know we see and I
click and I click and it's like patient
reported nothing and then you know again
some of my colleagues are great and
they've got like half their patients on
this with high blood pressure and it's
like click click click nothing nothing
nothing nothing nothing nothing so even
when it's enabled a lot of people are
either not checking it or not sending it
uh or there's some technical issues so
so it's interesting I think there are
multiple areas and I really agree I
think Oliver I think you hit the nail on
the head is this how do we intelligently
use this right you know you ask any
doctor they don't want more stuff in
their inbox right
um so you know how do we intelligently
use this data you know how do we put in
systems where we can do this and make it
scalable where there's not necessarily
always a human being like me covering
people's boxes you know clicking through
and and acknowledging them uh and then
because otherwise we just end up going
through this episodic care right this
this encounter based care and it's
sitting there but nobody's doing
anything with the data so a lot of of
interesting points with that challenge
I would add as another really great
insight for all successful programs I'll
give you an example the VA has launched
quite a huge preferred diabetic foot
ulcer prevention there's a company
called podometrics they have a smart mat
it's like a scale and it does a heat
generates a heat map when you step on it
every day
more than the technology this is what
they've told us so the podiatrist at
least they feel like they've seen better
outcomes in patients who are part of
these programs not necessarily because
of the technology but because the
technology connects them to a care
coordinator who follows up on you know
things
so if if nothing else this technology if
you can build it in so that it gives you
easier connection to the health system
and you're someone with a chronic
condition that needs better monitoring
oftentimes it's that human connection
that
you know is the magic sauce so I'll just
I'll just say that as an Insight that's
great you know my you know I've got
another hat on is like medical
Humanities and arts guy and yeah I mean
all these tools are just to support the
human interaction really at the end
that's great because there's actually a
question next about at the risk of
digital Health further distancing
patients from Physicians so I think you
kind of answered that question in a way
um
right yeah it's a tool we it's like
anything else some tools are good and
some tools are bad you can use them
inappropriately but you know it's I to
my mind never going to replace the human
interaction the goal would be to make it
more efficient better higher yield uh
where I'm not sitting there spending a
lot of time you know trying to figure
out somebody's insurance and what meds
are covered right that's not a good use
of my time uh I'd rather spend time to
talk about what the patient wants to
talk about
yeah and Brian also another another
really important point for successful
programs that I've seen
is is to um you know if you have you
need to have some sort of a coordinator
or someone to help you know engagement
is really tough you said you had a few
patients Brian that had zero engagement
others said I had great engagement and I
know from Ochsner again that when they
they had a full-time coordinator who
just responsible for pinging patients if
they didn't see blood pressures coming
in checking in you know oh we haven't
seen a blood pressure from you today
that that's really important for in
successful programs because
it's otherwise hard to get engagement
for today
this is also
also
um you know what is preventing State
pharmaceutical companies from using this
data that's being collected
um to develop drugs for profit and do
you have any thoughts on that
you know it's funny I was at a talk for
we have this there's this Bay Area in a
medical informatics society and the the
informatics fellows hold like a
symposium twice a year and uh one year
they had
um
uh the gentleman who's the head of the
Mayo's digital Health uh basically
yeah yeah used to be at Harvard and then
went to Mayo and uh you know they are
basically spent all this time
anonymizing their entire Mayo health
record for part of the goal is to you
know for drug Discovery and to let this
open and and uh I was kind of being
provocative you know I like to poke the
bear and I said I I send a question in
and and the fellows were the fellows are
moderating it much like Jackie you're
moderating and I said hey well you know
what do the patients get right and uh
there are models out there I think that
you know the correct venters working on
this and you know the human genome Guy
where patients will get paid based upon
sharing their data using their data
Mayo's response was you know kind of I
was less enthusiastic it was like well
you know this is helps everybody right
it's kind of the general well this is
research this also helps everybody but
you know it's kind of different I I my I
come down in that well if you you kind
of signed this blanket statement oh you
can use my stuff you know there's kind
of uh not a sort of Damocles but there's
a leverage there right you're like well
I want to get my care I'm here at Mayo
or wherever at Stanford wherever to get
care so I'm just going to sign whatever
because I need to see the doctor right
as opposed to you're in a clinical trial
somebody specifically explaining to you
what's the risk and benefit
and who's the benefit so so I'm I'm with
you there I think patients should be
somehow I don't know if anybody's
figured that out compensated for use of
their data I mean you look at companies
like Google right they have access to
hundreds of millions of people's records
right it's quite scary right
um I don't know if I trust Google with
that data uh even though they you know
it's a company that's like don't do evil
I'm like I want a company that does good
not just doesn't do evil right so it's
quite scary and I think that's quite
concerning I'm not sure what to do about
it
yeah I would just add that there's I
mean there are big companies billion
dollar companies that were formed around
this you know flat iron health for
example was bought by Roche and what
Flatiron did is they provided an
electronic health record system for free
to oncologists who were managing people
with cancer and that then selling that
data to Pharmacy or pharmaceutical
companies and Roche just went out went
out and bought them I think it was I
can't remember how many billion but it
was definitely over a billion so it's
very valuable it is an issue there's a
great appetite for that data data is
really the the oil
you know for the future
um right it needs to be refined to get
all the insights
thank you for that
okay I think we actually went a little
bit over so I think we're gonna wrap up
the webinar today thank you for all the
questions I know there are a lot of
questions that
um we didn't actually get to so
um thank you for submitting those and um
if you'd like to learn more actually
from Dr Lynn or Dr Alami uh feel free to
um check out their course which is
digital Health product development
um again you can click the QR code here
you can visit us on Stanford online to
enroll
um and we definitely encourage you to
check this out as well and a link to the
recording of the session will be emailed
to you within the next week or so so
feel free to visit this content
um again and once again thank you for
joining us today we hope you have a
great week and we hope to see you at our
next session thank you so much for
presenting to us today all right thanks
thanks so much
thank you everyone have a great rest of
the day